what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here John we are going to watch a
live-action fan film starring Nathan
Fillion for Uncharted this comes from
Alan Heung Garr before doing that of
course we got to give a page of the day
shout out if we're gonna give one today
it's a JT the man from Hawaii why
because this guy loves gaming and dude
we ever talk to you in such a long time
you are the man who gets me he's
creative you get me brainstorming I do
trailers revisited who wouldn't exist if
it wasn't for you we haven't done shows
you visited a long time because we
haven't talked to you I Love You Man
hope your parents are treating you well
not disciplining you too much can't wait
to talk to you in a couple weeks buddy
hey man get out there into the Hawaiian
you know jungles and stuff and go find
some treasure of your own you know good
job live that on Julian you made it you
made a relevant segue entertainment
purposes only I've played the Uncharted
and I played the first two I'm on the
third one I've watched you play a lot of
verses here this year civil chart and
this ship in the jump which need to need
against us the river lost the riches
[Music]
thank God for drones right
oh wait Nathan a billion is perfect to
play Nathan your eggplant funny you guys
cool that I've actually played the game
so I do yeah
we're gonna recognize so much content
fandom so I'm sure there should be a
walking there is
[Music]
[Music]
Ebola from data did you get it no this
is all he had on the bus hmm
I'm sure this actors are really nice and
real-life all the ones play Evil Dead
you guys
at that building of their review
[Music]
[Laughter]
legendary treasure hunter explore his
story
whoa hey I think you have me confused
with somebody else pal man responsible
for finding El Dorado then yes okay then
yeah that's me leads to like the hill
the private auction in La Paz a rare
item free valuable stolen an item my
employee rightfully purchase so imagine
my surprise when I find out that Nathan
Drake is in town sounds like quite a
coincidence tip nicely Toby
what exactly is this that is a compass
perhaps we can use it to find this
problem a haircut that didn't go out in
the 90s am i right guys where is I don't
know what is it I don't have it my
employer is not a man you want to cross
you've already made them quite angry I
do tend to have that effect on people
[Music]
let's try this once more shall we before
I violently remove something you care
deeply about camera cut sorry about that
let's hit play again so does that mean
if I care deeply about you okay okay
we'll see how cooperative you are after
a little time with ltaly
l who
you didn't know this
[Music]
sounds familiar you know that slang
[Music]
making up for cable right now going up
plans for the house now
just keep those guys busy a little
longer to say you know I put to get your
finger removed from some fella named El
Tigre I'm not sure everybody part if
they get a removing mmm
that's
Ernie race jr. oh that's el tigre thank
God guys oh who seriously
that's neat guys you got me you got me
those well-presented I was scared nipple
Jill all right you wanna be ready to go
[Music]
[Music]
I don't want to micromanage this thing
but you're supposed to be asking
questions and moving the budget just
consider this privilege Quran I hear
there many men who would be a great deal
to spend some time alone with you
awkward
music
[Music]
darn it second floor southeast corner
eat it do some chase and then shoot it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
actually stunt double
I raced you in real life to kick his ass
no problem hey game buddies showed up in
here good they seemed pretty pissed
about the bracelet yeah
don't you ever my face wouldn't be a
sore keep it a nice oh yeah nice and
toasty thanks right here I'm sort of
damper on things but what happens if
those letters aren't there close it be
until the solid that can't be top dollar
for a paid top dollar for security too
[Music]
one of his love interest to show me this
thing of the Oh Sully you really need to
check out this room
yeah maybe on the next door how are you
this guy's gonna be on to you in a
minute
uh here we go I found sell Albuquerque's
letters oh except I cannot mess around
he's got original copies to go back to
the conquest of Malacca Gary Dora
October 15 11 that's right before they
sailed back to Portugal in the Florida
Lamarr which is now sitting at the
bottom of the Indian Ocean
I'm telling you Nate it's Wild Goose
yeah well sounds like Sully the most
valuable lost treasure in history
wait a minute he's got a whole stack of
letters from Ferdinand Magellan to
Albuquerque earliest one is dated to
defeat weeks after the floor say so
so Magellan served under Albuquerque
during the conquest but history tells us
that's the last they saw of each other
[Music]
yes holy [ __ ] Sully do you know what
this means
dad whenever you start doing this nobody
knows what's gonna have to wait they
found your friends get the hell out of
there they grow a stache move
there's that open door
[Music]
wow this is so cool this is this is the
videogame
yes that's so cool
oh my god I have so many children
[Music]
[Music]
glass of wine yeah
I don't really film this in California
hey there she is
yep you know I always find myself
amazing unless you are incapable of
returning these things the way you found
them Wow you got the insurance you did
get the insurance right
I thought you do as promised right
treasure protect so we're gonna break
this open I feel like we're always
breaking things over hey did you see
this
mr. e Oh
oh well I'll be go to hell the triangle
not just Detroit oh it's the Trinity
Trinity oh my god of course when the
Florida Lamar sank it took 400 people
down with it but not Albuquerque he was
rescued by another ship called attend
dodgy Portuguese fraternity exactly down
history is spotty on who captained it
but there was another ship called the
Trinidad Spanish flagship famous for
having been the first to sail around the
world
Magellan captain the rescue ship
[Music]
Oh would you look at that
Oh Harlan
[Music]
it never made any sense
why would Albuquerque considered to be
one of the most brilliant military minds
in history put his treasure on the floor
Dylan Lara
as ship that had proven itself time and
time again to be unseaworthy what if the
reason no one has found the treasure of
the Florida lamar's because the treasure
was never on it it was longer-term dodgy
exactly it never sank and Magellan and
Albuquerque both would so what's this
then next time well Philippines I
understand whether the Filipino system
[Music]
feel like they should for credits or
like it ends acting or anything yeah
that was great dude that was awesome
it was really well done yes I've played
the first two games I have to buy part
three and get a ps4 so you played hard
for I don't know if this takes place
like after three or four I don't know
what happens in three or four so I don't
know exactly when the timeline of this
fast fan film takes place but in terms
of Breen uncharted 2 life they nailed it
of course if you up the production
design you can get crazier action scenes
and go do a little bit more like the
parkour stuff that Nathan Drake's known
to do hopping from building to building
a lot of the climbing it's like you're
not really gonna get that in a fan film
that is probably done for nothing but in
terms of capturing the essence of the
characters nathan fillion you here
Nathan feelings Nathan Drake you're like
that's perfect casting and you see here
he's perfect he delivers his lines like
Nathan Drake would deliver his lines he
has just the right look like maybe a
little bit older than when Nathan Drake
is in the games but he is perfect in
terms of delivery I was not expecting
Sully to be in this I thought oh just
gonna be Nathan Drake taking on these
guys so for Sully to be in this and they
get Steven lengths if it's funny because
Nathan Fillion seemed like he was doing
his own thing which naturally sounds
like Nathan Drake yeah I was gonna say
once his natural charm ease yeah not
usurps any of the age concern at all
your exact god the rhythm he's got that
he's got the rivets got the whole
cadence for a charm that sort of shackle
you know yeah and you know from a guy
who comes from like shows like Firefly
and Castle you know this guy can do
action sequences well he's always got
that that Nathan Fillion charm I feel
like yes just he turns that on and you
get it and it's exactly like Nathan
Drake for Stephen Lang to be in this I
thought his performance seemed like I
was questioning it going did he play the
games older dude just like play the
games cuz you're doing exactly what
Sully sounds - it is research I mean
like when I watch the cutscenes online
or something I've not played as much as
you but I played a little bit I've
watched you play it I think these fan
films are kind of a special thing you
know weirdly enough and
work like they really capture in that
whole moment where it transitions into
the combat mode yeah and you're over
your first like behind him then you go
over the right shoulder just such a
flawless transition into action moments
because it suddenly gives you the effect
of you're watching a cutscene and now
you're watching the game way yeah like I
wasn't even thinking on those terms and
when it happened I immediately wore
really transcribed this really
beautifully and I almost wonder if maybe
15 minutes is the ideal video game movie
and and this this script too is very
uncharted like in terms of when he's
picking up information the banter is
having with Sully while he's reading off
all the things he's kind of unfolding
it's always a lot to keep up with that
when I play the game I have to have it
with subtitles cuz I'll like lose a lot
of the information that made the drink
sort of spouting out about what is
uncovering here I was like oh cool you
took the time to put some historical
mystery in here and to involve here's
that we are all kind of aware of well
the way he gives the expositional
dialogue on it is exactly the way how
it's done in the game too they don't cut
around to like the past or anything it's
just him spouting off into a
walkie-talkie nine times out of ten to
Sully or Elena or whoever a chick is at
the time usually Elena and that was cool
I remember I was thinking like it's
you're gonna show up in this and then
she shows up at the end is it cool
Easter eggs I don't think they even
address her by her name which is neat
because that's strictly for the fans the
only that's missing is a bigger budget
uncharted is a game that would require a
bigger budget I think oh yeah I mean
this feels like just the first scene of
the movie basically yeah like what you
would do for a sizzle reel or something
that's breaking into Act two yeah yeah
yeah a little bit after the set up you
know but right before act 2 the main
transition yeah yeah a guy who loves the
first two games who was going to play
the third and fourth one this year yeah
I am I was super excited to see this and
looking at this I'm like why why can't
we get this over that Tom Holland thing
that they haven't developed what I was
thinking too because this of all of them
seems to be one where if this just did
well this could open a door for all
totally happen like if Nathan Fillion
showed up Stephen Lang like clearly
everybody wanted to do they make
this director seems to have a good
understanding of how to adapt it's like
I'm wondering what this work as a
full-length feature as a short film it's
kind of perfect all I'm wondering now is
that you know if you were to do a
feature film you got to go into like you
know historical landmark Sciences this
is like oh the script is good for what
this is but if you made an uncharted
movie you would inevitably have to go on
an adventure yeah you would you you
really would and you would have to do
research and do your reading and all
that sort of stuff
it's her a cool little fan film short
that was amazing Allen hung gar great
job everyone involved great job and it
wasn't over bloah and they didn't try to
do more than they could handle for a
short film I know they did just enough
to the point where you're not
questioning like maybe they shouldn't
have attempted this you know that sort
films do that you're like you needed a
budget to pull that off you should have
tried that yeah this is the right size
man and even just having them all three
together at the end I mean you spend the
least time with Elena but she's even
great like like everyone fair gather
really naturally and I think these fan
films when they're like this I mean the
few I've seen I get that they're hard to
make obvious yeah but it's kind of a
special way to get something like this
across because I got imagined to so many
fans heart swelling oh yeah totally yeah
this is amazing right now as we're
watching this a little over 700 K views
only 250 5 dislikes 54,000 likes this
this film is a success yeah
congratulations guys this is amazing
thank you for putting this together you
guys can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification melka subscribe
buttons are essentially broken and you
can check us out on patreon where we do
full-length TV show reactions and
reviews our weekly Q&A is music video
coverage love to have you become a
paycheck to day